ρα συνέτερξη πάνειες οι συνέντευξεις που δίνεται για αυτό υπα ότι ίνακαιδιαίτερ την ύπου είστε
μαζί μας σήμερα γιατί επιλέγεται να είστε μακριά από τα φώτα της δημοσιοτητας νομίζω είνα
είναι δεν είναι σωστό να είσετα συνέχεια στα φώτα έτσι στο νομίζω χεις οργισμένα πράματα
να πεις πρώτιμό να είμαιόταν θα μιλήσω να μιλήσωπερισότεο για τον εριθό σταυγό ν έχουμε
κάποια άλλιεγδήλωση για κάποιο από τα άλλα φιλανθρωπικα που ε τα οποία σχολούμε αλλά για
τον έαυτό υπρέπει να πωότι δεν μαγέσει να να μιλό και όλας για για τον
έ αυτόμου για τα ποθωπικά μου δεν είναι κάτι που που μου αγέσει και γι
αυτό και δεν έχω και θείς που κιτοπρόσεη ολανέψαναυρολικα στιχία για τη σημερήσέτεξι ότι απέχεται
για από αυτό ναι ούτε θέλω να προβάλω τον εαυτό μου αλλά και ούτε θέλω
να δεν θέλω να ξέω ότι κάμνει όλος ο κόσμος αν επείταξίδιαπ κεί παιδό και
διαφογά αλλα ωστόσο κυρια παβαδόπουλέ πολύ λένε ότι η ζωή σας είναι βγαλμένι από παραμύθει
από το παρύσει στη στράκα είναι έτσι κυρα απαδοπουλο είναι ένα παραμύθειδεν ξεχαν είναι παργαμύθειαλλα
είαι γιαμένα είναι η ζωή μου είναι υπραγματικότητα ότιμεγάλο σας το παρίσει και αγαπό παραπολύτηγαλεία
καισυνεχίζω και έχω πολύ να επαφή με την με τη γαλεία πηγαίνουμε κάθε χποια ενο
εγώ τουλάχιστον κάθε χρόνο και μετά για θα στυν κύπο επαντρέύτηκα και γιναταθα τα δούμε
στη συνέαααφού θέλωλν ξεγενήσουμε όπως είμα στε ν αρχή πλούσιο το φυλανθρωπικό σας έργο ειστεδιπλα
από πολύ κόσμο που έχει ανάγκη και αρχίσουμε από το να υθρό σταυρο τι ήταν
α